wenn du tun ein stück unserer kindheit
aber wie lange nach winnetou geht's an
den kragen schauen wir auf die seite 110
leute in die jagdgründe geschickt in die
ewigen der winnetou
salzburger verlag der das buch der junge
häuptlingen aus den regalen genommen er
als leiter politischer korrektheit
ausbau knysna weil den genannten minute
titeln sind wir so heißt es in der
erklärung des verlages nach abwägung
verschiedene argumente zu der
überzeugung gelangt dass angesichts der
geschichtlichen wirklichkeit der
unterdrückung der indigenen bevölkerung
hier ein romantisieren das bild wie
viele klischees gezeichnet wird vor
diesem hintergrund weil wir keine
verharmlosenden klischees wiederholen
und verbreiten weg mit winnetou winnetou
in die ewigen jagdgründe was ist denn da
los in diesem riesigen winnetou zoff
[Musik]
gänsehaut die hatte man damals als kind
wenn diese musik aus dem fernseher
ertönte und ist man ehrlich auch heute
noch als erwachsene
gebannt schauten wir auf die bildschirme
lassen karl mays bücher und saßen auf
den bänken in bad segeberg um die
heldengeschichten unsere idole winnetou
und old shatterhand zu erleben und diese
musik an die erinnert sich jeder
[Musik]
nostalgie pur erinnerungen an eine zeit
in der vieles noch einfacher war
[Musik]
3 jana und genau darum geht es das wort
indianer unsere redakteurinnen
beschäftigen sich intensiv mit themen
wie diversität oder kultureller
aneignung die kolleginnen diskutieren
die folgen für das künftige programm und
überarbeiten titel für titel unser
bestehendes sortiment
das kostet der verlag ravensburger nach
der veröffentlichung seines neuesten
winnetou kinderbuchs der hintergrund
kürzlich erscheint ein neuer film namens
der junge häuptling winnetou darin geht
es um den sohn des altbekannten
winnetous der auch wieder durch die
prärie reitet und mit freunden und
familie abenteuer erlebt
passend dazu erscheint ein buch zum film
vorerst
nach kritik aus den sozialen medien
beschließt der verlag ravensburger das
buch nicht mehr zu verkaufen in kinos
erscheint der film dennoch weiterhin im
programm die kritik aber lautet
rassismus und das bedienen von
stereotypen auch bild kolumnist und
rechtsanwalt joachim steinhöfel ist
schockiert dass der verlag gemacht hat
halte ich für ein feiges kapitulieren
vor denunzianten teilweise sind diese
leute anonym
ein zivilisatorisches versagen ein
verlag steht für kultur für presse für
bücher verdichtung und da schreien 200
leute auf twitter oder instagram und
schon kapituliert man die deutsche film
und medienbewertung hatte die winnetou
fortschreibung übrigens als besonders
wertvoll eingestuft gegen den
erbitterten widerstand einiger
jurymitglieder und der filmfernsehfonds
bayern hatte die produktion mit der
höchstsumme unterstützt satte
950.000 euro
eine kleine aber laute minderheit
prangert auf social media nun also das
wort indianer an
der große ravensburger verlag geht
sofort in die knie
ich übertreibe natürlich total
schwachsinnig kann ich nicht verstehen
ganz ehrlich warum den verkauf des
buches komplett einstellen warum das
wort indianer nicht einfach durch
apachen comanchen undsoweiter ersetzen
und neutronen warum bringt man das buch
nicht heraus und dann eine zweite
ausgabe politisch korrekte version
2022 vor alles geändert wird und alles
gestrichen wird und indianer und rothaut
und martha fall und fotos skalpieren
nicht vorkommt und dann kann man sich
aussuchen was man seinen kindern als
lektüre zumuten will und dann kann man
auch schauen wie viele leute denn dieses
buch kaufen 180 patienten auf twitter
haben sie ja schon mal zusammen das
vielleicht auch gleich für eine zweite
auflage da nicht erreicht was hätte
ravensburger stattdessen machen können
oder gar tun sollen unsere kinder werden
vorerst weiter die alten karl may bücher
aus einer zeit lesen müssen in der
damals so vieles so viel leichter war
und vergessen wir nicht karl may
propagierte weniger die stereotypen als
vielmehr die kulturübergreifende
freundschaft und das zusammenkommen
fremder völker und das war und ist immer
noch die wichtigste aussage
[Musik]
bei uns ist jetzt andreas brenner von
der universität potsdam er ist professor
für kunstpädagogik und auch kein experte
schön dass sie bei uns sind und sie
haben auch ihrem enkel mal kurz eine
private vorerfahrung heiliger vorgelesen
was war das für eine erfahrung wie lief
das ab mussten sie da worte verändern
und wie hat der enkel reagiert michael
ist ja noch relativ klein der ipv6 mit
dem war ich im kino ich habe im vorfeld
dieses kino gesuchte der heute 94 natur
habe ich ihm auch das ravensburger
erstleser buch vorgelesen und ihnen da
auch vorzubereiten und er war fasziniert
er war begeistert hat vor allen dingen
gefragt was sind eigentlich indianer und
darüber kann natürlich in einen dialog
der ebenso wichtig ist ja also was
bedeutet überhaupt die gene kulturen was
ist das gar nicht für eine faszination
die jetzt seit über 100 jahren quasi
eben manchmal deutsche mentalität mit
prägen und und begeistert ja also der
kleine enkel war sehr begeistert vom
jungen winnetou und hat das buch auch
was nicht verboten ist heute mit den
kindergarten genommen
wo dann zum glück noch nicht nur aus den
regalen genommen und bürger viel aber
das ist das missionsdesign
buch nicht geschützt genau weil ich
persönlich diesen seiner diese sind
transgene rational mythos ja also
winnetou ist in nationaler mythos
vergleichbar mit siegfried den
drachentöter gelungen liegt diese
transgene rationalen mythen sind einfach
wichtig und wieder auch der
psychoanalytische
literaturexperte heimat vor vielen
vielen jahren geschrieben hat kinder
brauchen mythen kinder brauchen
geschichten kinder brauchen bücher und
die geschichten die karl may und dieser
kann man kostenlos wird ja adressiert
vor dem buch was der tod thematisiert
ist eben auch die beschäftigung mit dem
fremden mit der alte reed also mit dem
anderen was uns passiert und was uns
auch quasi zu uns selber führen
eigentlich war sie eine
selbstbespiegelung wenn man sich mit so
genanntem fremden beschäftigt und die
den dialog mit dem fremden auf einer
fantastischen relativen gegner zu
erproben ist in dem jungen kindesalter
genau das richtige das tauchen kinder
also man kann viel mehr mit den kindern
dadurch ins gespräch riechen dass
vielmehr der weg als verbote oder bücher
aus den regalen zu nehmen sagen sie
diese öffentliche debatte die ist ja so
sehr im gange jetzt man hat das gefühl
man muss sich von ganz vielen was man
aus der kindheit kennt für immer
verabschieden was glauben sie wo führt
das hin wenn das wirklich so wäre es für
das allzu einer sage mal gewissen
sterilität und langeweile das ist
natürlich auch so dinge die gehen immer
wieder schon passiert ja also in den
zwanziger jahren gab es heinrich wolgast
der berühmte reformpädagoge und
literatur pädagoge damals schon vor den
schund im bücherschrank gewandt und
versucht auch hochwertige kinder und
jugendliteratur zu empfehlen diese
bücher kennt aber keiner mehr und der
steht schon anführungszeichen ist
geblieben weil der schwund in ein
führungszeugnis das was die kinder und
jugendliche fasziniert ja also die
spannenden geschichten die abenteuer das
hineinversetzen in eine fremde welt das
ist ja auch geblieben heute ist es in
der regel also marvel universums ii
universen und der fantasy bereich der
kinder- und jugendliteratur ist ja
risikos also wonisch etwas fremdes zu
erleben sich eine andere welt hinein zu
versetzen ist absolut entwicklungs
spezifische geboten eigentlich ganz
schnell einmal der test mit ihnen ja
oder nein darf man indianer sagen och ja
darf man weil es mir selbst bezeichnete
indigenen bevölkerung der usa darf sich
ihr enkel als indianer verkleiden ja
genau das ist verkleidet ist extrem
wichtig weil die auseinandersetzung mit
etwas fremden bedarf halt der
anverwandlung und witzig ist eine form
der selbst reflexivität also im falle
sehr zugeführt und was würden sie sagen
wenn sie mir heute beim frühstück oder
beim mittagessen gegenüber sitzen würden
aufhören mit schreiben nicht mehr nicht
mehr oder nächste folge weiter schreiben
und kann man hat sich ja auch stark
verändert hat die die letzten jahre
hatte natürlich große symbolistische
literatur geschrieben da ist winnetou
quasi ein edel mensch edel mensch ist
ein kontrast zu nietzsches übermensch
also wissen eine friedensbotschaft die
er versucht hat auch dank man irgendwie
lethargisch umzusetzen aufbauend auf
seinen sage ich mal abenteuerlichen
roman seiner mittleren zeit also kann
mal war immer auf dem guten weg da kann
andreas preßel der von der universität
potsdam kommt und dort professor für
kunstpädagogik ist kaum ein experte hier
bei detlef tanke vielen dank auch
[Musik]